so it's interesting inflation is
obviously going up they say it's a
little over six percent it's obvious
clearly much higher than that in some
places with some products
no one likes this except people who have
massive amounts of debt that is
certainly suddenly costing them less to
pay off but the average person is hurt
by this and hates it and maybe that's
why the people who know better than you
are suddenly telling you that inflation
is great
it's good that everything costs more
you do make a really good point that
inflation as a product of demand um has
an upside correct
right to the extent that it's coming
from a strong strong economy a strong
consumer that's not you know that that's
not a bad thing this is the fastest
recovery right now in recent memory
demand is high wages for the bottom 40
percent of workers are rising very fast
fast enough to help overcome what is the
big central problem that everyone is
rightly discussing right now inflation
while nobody likes to pay more on
average we have the money to do so
household savings hit a record high so
republicans want you to believe the
economy isn't doing well that's terrible
but in reality unemployment is at its
lowest point since before the pandemic
began so the economy isn't
bad it's just that people are mad
because everything is late and things
cost a little bit more
these people are so partisan they'll
literally say anything they'll look
right into the camera and lie
as long as it helps their political
candidate in this case joe biden
i mean you've got to think if people
started to starve to death
they would tell you it's good because
the country is too fat
over at cnn one of their anchors just
tweeted a picture of a refrigerator
stocked with milk he said that's proof
there is no supply chain crisis because
of course we import all of our milk from
china these people are too stupid to be
real
meanwhile joe biden's nominee to a top
treasury post a communist sympathizer
called saleamarova is refusing to say
whether she believes high gas prices are
bad for the country watch this
dr omarova do you think that higher gas
prices are good for america or bad for
america yes or no answer would be fine
there
senator
that's a tricky question because i do
remember uh
higher gas prices good for america or
bad for america doctor it's probably bad
for america it's not it's not my
expertise i'm not sure exactly what
you're asking mr chairman i'd let the
record reflect
that this witness is having a hard time
acknowledging that higher gas prices are
bad for america
are higher gas prices bad for america
what's a tricky question i guess they're
bad which doesn't care none of them care
they're for higher gas prices
they're for ending the energy industry
which by the way is our last functioning
sector of the economy in the united
states they'll be real poverty if they
succeed in doing that but meantime they
just don't care about its effect on you